greets everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where today we're talking
about console was buckle up this is kind
of a remake of a video I made I don't
know five years ago that I actually made
private because I got sick of all the
arguing my stance has not changed in
five years so I don't know if it's just
me but it feels like console wars are at
an all-time high
maybe that's the industry that I walk in
maybe that's just the growth of social
media means that we're seeing more and
more of it but to me it seems like
people who are on Xboxes team are on
Playstations team a far more aggressive
than they have ever been before if you
say something positive about Playstation
you're a Sony shill you've been
brainwashed you don't know what you're
doing if you say something positive
about Xbox you're an idiot you don't
have any exclusives you're delusional
you're clearly losing the race if you do
either of those things while working in
games media as I do it means that one of
the other paid you off not a thing why
would they need to do that when everyone
in the comments is arguing about which
one is better without us even prompting
them to to answer the question who is
winning the console wars its Xbox and
its PlayStation every single time
someone jumps in a comment section and
argues about which brand is better the
only person who wins is that brand and I
just think it comes from a place of
people wanting to validate that
purchasing decisions people basically
being like well I bought this one I am
going to argue about why this one is
better and why Ulysses was so that I
feel better about the fact that I spent
my money on this one there is no other
reason for someone who owns a
Playstation to be angry about Xbox other
than because it gives them an ego boost
because it gives them a sense of purpose
because it gives them the idea that they
chose the right team for my stance
personally I own both I also own a PC
and I play literally all of them and I
think the weirdest part of that that I
experience is that Xbox fans
well sometimes say I'm not a real Xbox
gamer because I also on PlayStation it's
absurd
a hundred percent I think that if you
have the money to and you have the
opportunity to you should buy both
consoles you should have both consoles
if you don't you're missing out on
incredible experiences that exist on
both of these platforms if you feel
passionately enough that you bought the
right thing that you will argue with
people in a comment section totally
unprovoked that you will come here to
this video and yell about why your
choice was better you're being robbed a
company has done such a good job of
getting your loyalty that you hate
another thing that can give you
different experiences so I asked my
patreon what that take on console was
was without the connotation of what I
would be making on this video and I
really like this is something Michael
that scalice said he said console was
basically just the end result of
marketing strategies which push in group
versus out group narratives and which
are designed to get people to identify
parts of that personality with whatever
item is being sold people who identify
themselves specifically as Playstation
or Xbox gamers are more likely to stick
with their respective brands than
someone who just sees themselves as a
person who plays games at will and
unintended with pretty obvious results
of this is that people will fight over
which of the multibillion-dollar
corporations selling luxury goods is
making the most money and I 100% agree
with that I just feel like instead of
siding with the marketing ploy that
these companies so desperately want
because you're helping them sell
something and you're kind of confirming
to them that you will repeatedly buy
their thing that we would think about
the community of gaymans as a community
think of games as a thing for us to
enjoy rather than a thing for one
company or the other to be number one
the one benefit to the console was
existing is that people constantly
talking about which of the two is better
does create a conversation around the
competition for those brands meaning
that they are constantly getting
feedback about what one company is doing
right what the other company is doing
right and having two of them is very
important like anyone who says and I see
this a lot Xbox should just die Xbox
should just give up and die I promise
you you do not want that
the minute that PlayStation is the only
of those brands that exists they don't
have any reason to be compared
if they know and you're kind of telling
them this anyway that you're going to
buy their box and that the other one
doesn't exist they're going to increase
prices for things they're going to spend
less money on things PlayStation doesn't
need exclusives if they think that
you're going to blindly buy that console
anyway they'll stop making them the
reason that they make those first party
single-player experiences is to sell
hardware that's why they fund those it's
not because the brand is superior it's
because someone who's very high up at
Sony is literally saying we need to make
people buy this god of war will make
people buy this if Xbox doesn't exist
Sony loses reason to do that and I think
that's like probably one of the things
that's [ __ ] this is the weird
hostility that I see towards Xboxes play
anywhere program it's very odd play
anywhere for those of you who don't know
means that if you buy something on Xbox
you can also immediately download it on
your PC just by signing them to the
Windows Store with the same email
address I've done that much times there
are plenty of games that I have bought
on my PC or bought on my xbox that I
then downloaded on the other one this is
great for a bunch of reasons it means
that you can seamlessly play [ __ ] anyway
as the title would suggest but for
whatever reason the PlayStation fanboys
take this is meaning that there are less
Xbox exclusives and and they say that
like like it's an argument in the favor
of Playstation but it's something that's
good for people
this is literally a company saying that
people don't have to buy the same thing
twice and that it's available for more
people to play this is good it's so
weird to see them criticized for that
solely from the standpoint of well my
box has more exclusives so screw a pro
consumer practice from a multi-billion
dollar company also yeah I didn't talk
about Switch in this video which is of
course a a totally valuable addition to
the console market that I really enjoy
playing but for whatever reason and this
isn't my exclusion um the switch very
rarely seems to come up in consoles just
wanted to clear it up for their comments
about it that people don't tend to talk
about the switch quite as much of quite
as aggressively we'll talk about
Nintendo quite as much of white as
aggressively as people do with Xbox and
Playstation that's the only reason that
I didn't focus on it in this video okay
you guys I hope you enjoyed this video
I'm Alana
you to everyone who gave me some really
cool insight about this on patreon and
to everyone's whose names are on screen
right now for supporting me on patreon I
will see you guys next time